so also sind es kann sein dass geistige
entwicklung kann man sehr gut beobachten
das leben als begründung stunts oder man
könnte auch sagen
als begründung ersatz eine anfangs noch
fast intuitive und später immer
bewusstere und unsere stellung einnimmt
in wenigen schritten beginnt leistung
von dem zwei singles gesprochenen frühem
späten dem stifter schied mit da wir uns
verlieben soziologischen und dem
späteren lebensphilosophische ob das
sinnvoll ist darüber kann man sich mit
milliarden immer grund streifen man kann
auch von 300 sprechen und davon vier
andere gibt es alle möglichkeiten hier
irgend kategorie machen aber das ist gar
nicht wie das thema meine vortrag runde
es geht eher darum wie sich das leben
als berufsschule kategorie schon fast
unverschämt rüsten sind durch mit der
zeit wann bricht und letztlich zu einem
prinzip wird das den prinzipien des
idealisiert entgegen gestellt wird also
dann erst werk schnee gebracht und sind
wirklich die geschichte der
lebensphilosophie die auch schon in
seiner vorgeschichte vorher anfängt mit
der romantik arbeite bedingt er wird
mich in dem moment wo das leben zum
prinzip wird schon in den frühen
christen das leben ein maßstab für das
gesunde richtige echte wirklich an die
mehr oder weniger alles gemessen wird
also wir haben nicht mehr den
richterstuhl der verdienstvollen alles
gezerrt wird sondern wir haben für den
richterstuhl das leder zum beispiel sagt
nun in seinem sehr froh in praktischen
aufsatz über die religionslehrer dann
das was sich am ende durchsetzt ist war
also dass es wahr was dem leben dient
das leben ist ein quiz denken irgendwann
wieder eine aufgehende sonne am horizont
ein hoffnungsschimmer in düsteren zeiten
leben ist für sinne ein kampfbegriff und
ein paar wohnung in der viel zeichen
gegen eine intellektualismus oder
wachsen als lebensfeindlich wolle
zivilisation legen ab 6
in konventionen erstarrte lebens könnte
bildung zieht leben prophezeit himmel
werde im zwanzigsten jahrhundert zu
einem zentral beruft der philosophie und
er sowie sein natur oder gott in anderen
epochen liegt die philosophie wie gesagt
in der krise als ein ausgefülltes
intellektuelle britische unternehmen an
und sein gegenmittel ist angeht
verlebendigung der philosophie er fragt
man sich natürlich für diese vielen
verwendungen des lebens der
verlebendigung was das eigentlich alles
sagen soll was heißt denn hier das etwas
dem leben gehen muss das heißt hier das
öffnen und so viel verlebendigt werden
soll
wie soll das überhaupt aussehen und die
rede darüber ebenso sehr diffus dass das
leben ist es nicht begrifflich gefasst
aber es gehört eben auch zum programm
dazu dass das wellcome offen bleiben
muss
denn das leben das wissen vom leben sagt
schlimmes ist ein intuitives
unmittelbare daher nicht begrifflich raz
war
gute zeiten für begriffsstutzige
menschen wenn man hier einfach mit
intuition ja sozusagen wir sehen
nachspüren kann lebensphilosophie
erscheint hier 18 und als das mittel für
himmel um sich vom sozialismus vom
psychologisch musst du zugreifen
mit dem sinne mit dem leben kann sie mit
jenen endlich wieder das ganze denken
er äußert doch auch selbst so er will
explizit metaphysische stendebach
schreibt hier von der suche nach dem
verloren gegangenen oder verloren
geglaubten absoluten nach hegel das nun
eben durch ersatz konzepte kompensiert
werden muss und ein solches
erwerbskonzept weiter neben auch das
leben als prinzip leben ist das einzige
dieser ergab konzepte in dem dann auch
wieder das ganze gedacht wird aber das
ganze hat einen im wesentlichen
irrationales herbert schnädelbach geht
so weit dass er von der
ebenso viele seiner metaphysik des
irrationalen spricht das würde ich jetzt
nicht unbedingt für unterstreichen denn
leben ist ja auch das wären wir gleich
noch sehen geistiges leben und das
geistige enthält eben auch rationalität
was man zusammenfassend sagen kann ist
dass das leben hier zu einem alles um
greifender zusammenhalt wird zu etwas
das immer schon da ist und dass alle den
geist die kultur und das individuelle
bewusstsein umschließt und trägt und
schließlich die frage wozu braucht
himmel innerhalb dieser neben
philosophischen welt alles das wird man
dadurch erforderlich damit im geist im
blut etwas wie touristisches eine
vitalis tische funktion der natur
gemeint ist leben ist mehr nächsten
ordnet sich der mensch nicht frage zitat
ordnet sich der mensch nicht fraglos in
die natur eins lässt hier seine beiden
kultur theoretischen schriften werden
mit einem solchen statement eingeläutet
was das ist was den menschen vom tier
tag los animalischen unterscheidet mich
persönlich wird es ist der geist zitat
dass der mensch sich in die natürliche
gegebenheit der welt nicht fraglos
einordnet wieder vier sollen sich von
ihr los reißen gegenüberstellt fordern
dringend vergewaltigt sind alle so
lebensphilosophischer ausdrücken dass
vergewaltigung das kommt immer wieder
ins treffen der fed zum ganz starke
körperliche ausdrücklich weil das
irgendwie haben gestern zur mehrfach vom
losreißen gesprochen bezug auf ständige
und hegel und dieses lot reifen was wir
hier sehen
das ist etwas anders als das was wir
gehört haben bei den idealisten des
tableaus reifen ein geist gepackt aber
beim engel ist die liefersituation
ansprache etwas körperliches ein akt der
natur etwas das in der wirklichkeit
stattfindet bei der mensch baut
werkzeuge waffensammler und bauern und
auf diese weise 3
wer sich von der natur durch den
menschen unterscheidet ist dass er
sozusagen eine schöpferische 4 ist er
selbst natur
es liegt gebildet zu produzieren die
eben keine natur zu beziehen
zum unterschied von tier und mensch
natur aber dieser unterschied ist eben
nicht im sinne eines tourismus gemacht
sondern hier im sinne einer kontinuität
geist sachsen ist die höchste stufe des
lebens erfasst eine quelle im leben
er sagt an einer stelle da schwingt sich
das leben über das berufs animalisch
lina und auch um aus dem vater der
schwingt immer irgendwas das leben
schreitet voran von der stufe des
geistes land zu derjenige der kultur
also kultur das ist sozusagen die form
des geistigen kulturen das ist auch
nicht im sinne von national- und dinge
gemein sondern es kann auch die kultur
der sport geben oder kultur im sinne von
einem bestimmten lebensstil und so
weiter allerdings wohnen zu dir in
diesem aufschwingen
kein plan kein ziel das logisch das
leben strömt und ist kontingent und auch
das hervorbringen des geistes ist nicht
notwendiges sondern etwas zufälliges
leben gibt es auch ohne geist findet und
dass man irgendwann der geist
vorgebracht wird york das ist dann
ebenso geist bis dann eben sich welt
eigentlich lieferzeiten noch kein
computer und keine debatten und
künstliche intelligenz begleicht man
aktive diskussion als verlängerung der
problem der nationalisierung des geistes
so sieht man dass die künstliche
intelligenz um komplexe operation
verlässlich und kräftiger ausführen kann
wetter und verlässlicher sogar als der
mensch selbst
was aber hier fehlt ist die
schöpferische eigendynamik das lebendige
das lebendige das geistesleben des
geistes
beziehungsweise es gibt gar keinen geist
oder leben die geister nicht künstlich
hergestellt werden
der religion wenn wir dann wenn wir nach
den bedingungen fragen unter denen der
geist zu ihnen jeden fruchtbaren und
schöpferischen tätigkeiten viel gibt
dann kann man hier schnell auf die idee
kommt von analogen eigenschaften zum
lebendigen organismus zu sprechen
unter den lebensphilosophische
voraussetzungen hier macht gehört auch
dazu dass diese vermeintlichen analogien
ihm nicht als analogien gesehen werden
sondern wegen haft bedingt sind die
geistigen tätigkeiten sind wenn wir
folgen tief in organischer
lebensprozesse gegründet die
charakteristischen strukturen des
geistes während vorgänger als eine
weiterentwicklung grundlegender lebens
struktur interpretiert sind wir wieder
beim losreißen verspricht nämlich eben
außer jetzt an dieser stelle ihn nicht
davon dass sich der geist und wie von
leben los greifendes die natur wird auch
nicht als etwas fremdes begriffen in dem
sich der geist nicht findet organe führt
und geistiges leben denkt himmel in ein
formel 1 wirklich sehr harmonischen
verband geistige subjektivität hier also
leiblichkeit dort das lied für will
nicht mehr wirklich ein expliziter
eigentlich überlebt
die anthropologischen dimension von
leiblichen gefühlen wie hier ein träger
flexi dispositionen und einstellungen in
villingen eventuell für die entstehung
einer selbstbewussten individualität
dazu kommt dass sie zwar vom leben im
sinne von dunklen trieben spricht aber
dass momente zerstörerischen oder
potenziell zerstörerischen des lebens
eigentlich gar nicht mit thematisiert
das leben ist für winnenden erster linie
etwas spenden und frösche das positive
der freien lauf lassen muss obwohl und
muss ihm auch das glück stahl ist dies
zu tun
das leben sagt seine kraft über uns der
gärten der der geist beherrscht das
leben nicht diese besagt dass leben will
nicht beherrscht
ein verliehen was uns auch wieder als
die tat bei den christen findet sich der
gedanke dass das notwendige nicht
steuerbar ist der lebensweise aber keine
transparente macht sondern sie kommen
aus dem leben selbst das leben hat
keinen sinn
außerhalb seiner selbst die frage nach
der moral kunst gott lassen sich nach
wien wo durch die suche nach den
ursachen des lebens begegnen
er sagt so suche nach den ursachen
da fragt man sich jetzt was das jetzt
wieder sein
hierzu lässt sich sagen dass die
lebensphilosophie reflektiert einen
alten die menschen bewegen den gedanken
auf nimmt nämlich dafür gebaut das leben
nicht begriffliches aussagen können was
das leben ist das ist nicht bekannt war
es ist nur metaphorisch in einem
analogen gewinner beschreibbar
ursprünglich hatte das leben und
freiheit die der welt bewegung das heißt
dass sich das lebendige welt bewegt
hiervon ausgehen könnte angenommen
werden dass es ein paar beziehungsweise
ein ersten unbewegte wege gibt die auch
tun sagt doch sie haben es gehört das
leben soll ja auch sich selbst besetzen
werden man soll und nicht auf
transzendente mächte zurückgreifen
woher das lebendige dann sein leben hat
wird metaphorisch gesprochen verdunkelt
das lebensprinzip ist demnach ein zitat
dunkler grund oder unergründliche
grundlage unseres seins wenn du spricht
von dem dunklen um flächen und aufgrund
des lebens dieser uhr und wird hier in
gewisser weise bewusst unbegründet
gelassen
literarische ausgedruckt wird so auf dem
prinzip des liftverbundes
die metapher des dunklen unterbunden ein
grund der jenseits kognitiv erfassbaren
nimmt und wenn überhaupt dann nur
erspürt werden kann
am besten natürlich vom künstler das
begründen das locker die dort unter
diesen lebensphilosophische vorzeichen
nicht mehr als das kerngeschäft der
philosophie gewertet
es geht hier vielmehr um das finden von
treffen in bildern und metaphern 50
einwenden dass die rede vom dunklen und
einen rückschritt hinter den
rationalismus bedeutet nach der von uns
wurde erdoberfläche sagen
doch in der bezugnahme auf die dunkle
seite der antike steckt insoferne
aufklärung schritt als das tier der
verlust der glaubwürdigkeit oder
überzeugungskraft rationalisten
verdenken modelle in der nach reguliert
wird
sie markiert das bewegen oder das werden
weil ein eigenes verhältnis der dinge
zur häufigkeit oder beschaffen hatte
aber nicht auf einer länge von fixierten
lagen oder sein zuständen
zusammenzusetzen
freilich mit liebe letztere der
aktionistischen klarheit und
begrifflichkeit die entwicklung und die
sehnsucht der klassischen denken zwar
sehr viel mehr als das anerkennen das
wäre aus einer völlig primären kategorie
in ihnen scheint tatsächlich etwas
dunkles gemüse zu liegen und erst eine
viel entwickelter stufe des denkens
findet nicht mehr in der einfachheit es
sein die alleinige alles begreifende
instanz sondern gibt es eine auflösung
in werden die koordinierte er vielleicht
die tiefer begründen stellung
zitat ende der vernunft auf die massen
des rationalismus erscheint hier aus als
seicht und unrealistisch die
lebensphilosophische einsichten dagegen
sind peer aktionistischen wintern wieder
oberflächlich und in dem sich hier die
rationalisten für klarheit
als sehnsucht der klassischen deutschen
denken bedeutet psychopathie
pathologisiert er dieses als eine
verständliche reaktion auf
problematische historische bedingungen
verschärft den idealismus beraubt ihn
mit seiner psyche ergebnis seiner
aktiven grundlage stellt im innenraum
als historisch immer unten da sie mit
lebensphilosophie ist als spekulativ und
womit folgt hier seinen lehrer dilthey
der sagt janßen heute von der realität
ebenso ausgehen im leben ist die
totalität der dänischen zusammenhangs
wirksam gegen konzert metaphysisch wir
analysieren das gegebene ja daran
orientiert sich simmel beziehungsweise
das gehört auch zu seinem eigenen
programm
er hat in seiner zeit in rust der
zauberer in der ein realistisch ein
relatives dann eben hier seinen freund
lem maler der zeit sagt und mir ist
dieser dieser idealistische kinder
glaube wer will lieber er möchte wieder
ideal ist ein
aber er kann nicht und dann gibt es eben
den himmel der eigentlich alles
entzaubert und alles kaputt macht er
will gar nicht so einiges realistischer
aber das ist eben die moderne und der
wille war sozusagen der inbegriff genau
in dieser moderne leichter kann man auf
der anderen seite neben dieser
realistischen komponenten sagen dass
sinne
man könnte ja ick mathis muss nehmen
das ist das was immer der
nationalisierung des geistes
entgegenstellt leben ist geheimnisvoll
mystisch unfassbar und vor allen dingen
etwas was in der tat für eine unfassbare
mystische das ist hier der frei für die
aufgabe der letzten gründe sind spricht
hier verging sich auftun und abgrund das
rätselhafte wird hier in luzern zum
prinzip gemacht nach dem motto wie bei
die dinge in ihrer rätselhaftigkeit und
düsterkeit zu akzeptieren wie sie eben
sind aus spekulativen von wirklichen
leben wird es in dem abgetrennten
gedankengebäude hinterherzulaufen
das hat natürlich auch ganz praktische
nach dem motto man muss sich davor ein
denken weil der islamismus gehemmt
sozusagen die lebenskraft
wenn ich hier mein freund vierbeiner
zitiere aus
in deutschland nichts bekannt bücher
über server storage vertuschung und
retov riesenrad zu mir gesagt
energiepass auf mit dem er selber hat
über hegel promoviert und sagt regeln
promovenden brauchen im durchschnitt
weglachen länger angesichts dieses
dunklen abgrund das aber denn jetzt hier
auftut sollte man sich das doch noch mal
überlegen mit dem studium des deutschen
idealismus
denn mit der lebensphilosophie das wird
immer gesagt jedes mittel seien hier dem
von ihr gar nicht wegzudenken ist zu
vereinigen da hilft dann auch nie zurück
wir verpasst nichteinhaltung geteilt das
ist etwas was sich auch in der zweiten
hälfte des letzten jahrhunderts in
sämtlichen bereichen kulturellen lebens
wieder findet der ablehnung der
sogenannten helle nannte der winckelmann
antike der altägyptische ideal und aber
immer strahlt weist die körperwelten
sowie die ungebrochene ruhig der
winckelmann gestalten
das provoziert natürlich ein
gegengewicht die jetzt wenn franz von
stuck frank ihre haft düsterer mit user
aus den jahren 1892 gehen oder auch
volquartz images betont der spätphase
der antike das wilde regionale als das
eigentlich interessante auf derzeit
spricht davon wie die heutige analyse
der menschlichen existenz und alle mit
dem gefühl der gebrechlichkeit erfüllt
der macht des dunklen ritters airlines
an den dunkelheiten das ist dass derlei
eigentlich gar nichts an guten ton zu
halten
das ist eher symbolischer große dem sinn
von das land gerne horrorfilme
vittek abc beispiel erst holzwerke
werfen ihm vor dass jemand ist der ml
klose haltlos
die moralische kompass verloren gegangen
ist in dieser philosophie die nicht
begründen wenig mehr gebunden kann ja
erst in der einleitung der moral
wissenschaft ein ganz entscheidender und
entschiedener vertreter des moralischen
relativismus und der wird eben nicht als
der dunkelheit oder an die
wahrhaftigkeit verzweifelt liegt daran
dass er sich irgendwie und leben
aufgehoben gefühlt gute seiten erhält
letztlich aber hat man eben immer das
gefühl dass er an der schöpferische
spenden die normative kraft des lebens
wirklich glaubt ja und nur so kann er
nicht den leben ganz hingeben
diese lebensphilosophie hätten sich
nicht dem leben zugewendet man sie
hätten sich ihm hingegeben diesem
hingeben an das leben ist ein gewisser
fatalismus inhärent angeblich äußere
nicht anheim
weil ihm die vernunft nicht mehr der
überflüge wichtrup ist sondern das leben
geht ihm das leben auf ihn ehren von
denen man nicht zwei wenn die vernunft
oberster gerichtshof ist dann verfügt
die vernunft über sich welt und liefert
es muss mehr geht ihm auch der verlust
von autonomie kümmern macht an einer
stelle da geht es um seine fraktion zur
freiheit da sagt er
schlechtes feiert auch ganz lustig da
hin gerostet von hans schweickardt als
ob freiheit
ob wir uns ob wir frei sind oder nicht
das ganze thema hauptsache wir führen
und 3 wenn auch ganz im sinne dieses
erleben und lebendigen die rheinische
variante der lebensphilosophie
obwohl die tiere ständig berühren wird
welche geheiligt moment geschäft das den
anschein hat und gerne mit geis begriff
steht im sinne eines künstlerischen
lebens in die ahl das verhältnis
befestigung zu leben und im verhältnis
das geistige zum leben und sich darum
gehen den guide lebendig zu halten
die frage ist nicht ob es klappt oder
woher kommt er
das gibt eigentlich unter diese
lebensmittel verkauft wenn für eine
sinnlose frage sondern sich auch die
lebensmelodie einlädt dann fragt man
nicht mehr nach konzerne oder
begründungen von geistern funktion des
lebens ist das geld irgendwie für das
leben dort auch selbst gefunden dann ist
folglich auch der in seinen beiden
kultur philosophischen aufsetzen
ein retina mission begriff von kultur
unter der dort geäußerten prämisse muss
auch das verhältnis von geist und leben
verstanden werden
kultur manche zum einen die objektive
aktionen in dem sich ein der
subjektivität entspringen des
lebensalltags also den objektiven
geistlichkeit und von anderen
beziehungsweise umgekehrt weil kultur
hier die formierung einer welle die sich
aus der natur zur kultur erfuhr arbeitet
also nicht die bildung des subjektiven
geistes sind erfolgt hier her da um
leute und ihre extremistischen extra
findet mystischen bildungsideal de
luftiges bildungsprozess ist die
steigerung des individuellen lebens und
diese version erhält der subjektive
geist entschieden die oberhand gegenüber
dem objektiv beziehungsweise die
kultivierung der subjekt hat vorrang vor
der objektiven kultur konturierten
kontext und natürlich der künstler hat
sich viel mit künstlerpersönlichkeiten
beschäftigt mit einem verlangsamten
hinten und dann absoluter liebling ist
modelle wurde und für ihn der inbegriff
der schütze seine eigene dynamik
zwischen leben anschauen
er schwärmt in form seiner werke von den
bisweilen bis zur absurden verrenken
liegenden klar verhalten
die figuren modernen das ist moderner
rakitic wie immer sagt während classic
stillstand ist oder platonisch muss auf
druck verwendet er dafür wenn moderne er
aktiv muss das ist irgendwie das
kabarett nur auf das auf die moderne
bezogen wird auf jeden fall ist der
künstler derjenigen die sich das
geistige auch noch mal steigern weil er
schöpferisch tätig ist und vor allen
dingen der klavier- oder der die
bewegung gleich zu seinem prinzip erhebt
denn das allerschlimmste
der stillstand erfahren auch eine
tragödie kultur die man zusammenfassen
können die die geistige produkte also
der geist ist da das leben strömt aber
weiter es gibt derzeit viele
untergangspropheten wie zb von klages
untergang der erde am geist oder bzw
ehrgeiz als widersacher der viele
verlage oder untergang der seele am
geist von lessing will kann man gar
nicht so richtig von einer
untergangspropheten sprechen denn das
was hier mit tragödie gemeißelt sind
eigentlich gar nicht so dramatisch das
ist eher eine beschreibung sagen ich
jetzt die tragödie ist also eine frage
so verhält verhängnis zum unterschied
gegen ein trauriges oder von außen
zerstören das zeichen wir das verdient
doch die gegen ergeben berichteten von
nicht mehr kräfte auf den tiefsten
schichten im liebes wesen selbst
entspringen dass sich mit seiner
zerstörung ein schicksal verdient
das sind ihm selbst angelegt und
sozusagen die logische entwicklung in
der struktur ist mit der das wesen seine
eigene positivität aufgebaut hat nicht
ein drohen gepflegt
ende sondern ein 6 widerspruch der
kultur der fall gewesen unabdingbar ist
um hier tragödie in einem dramatischen
sinne gemeint man könnte auch sagen dass
man das tragische hier nicht über
translate problem wird daraus eben nur
wenn ihm so viel objektiver geist die
kultur hält da sagt er hier das sein
vater richtige übereifer müder
gewordener epochen nur die unfähigkeit
besteht zur einbeziehung des wach
gehalten subjektive kultur also da
spricht er natürlich von seiner eigenen
falsch und absurd hinterher weitet sich
dann aus zu radikal dams theorie dann am
vorabend des ersten weltkriegs seinen
krieg schriften sagte das einzige was
wir hier noch helfen kann in unserer
situation wo ihre kulturelle liegt mir
weitergeht das wäre eine ausstellung im
sinne des krieges aber man muss eben
sagen da ist er nicht der einzige der
damals argumentiert und später wird er
das auch nicht mehr auf gemessen
was man aber sagen kann abschließend ist
das wenn man diesen anspruch dass der
geist lebendig gehalten werden swatch
versucht gerecht zu werden indem eine
primäre philosophie auf eine geradezu
programmatisch art und weise eben
lebendig macht als thematische dafür
werde in einem intuitiven alltags
sprachlichen sinne eingesetzt
er versucht mit vielen dynamischen
kräftiger ausdrücken zu arbeiten wie in
das schwingen oder vergewaltigen
von dem lebendigen sprache die forderung
nach konkreten darf nicht abstrakt sein
und das ist auch eine von hundert
stärken
vorher macht lobt als jemanden der eine
generation von jagdwaffen heidecker die
studenten ermutigt hat auch den waren
der fußball
heraus zu springen und konkret zu denken
was das eben auch heißen solle konkrete
denke dass mehrere aspekte dazu gehört
eine vereiterung der philosophie im
alltäglichen und zeit aktuellen wobei
wenig echte zeitdiagnose abliefert
sondern immer versucht auf der an
schwung am konkreten etwas allgemeines
zu entwickeln und das geld dann verluste
mussten auch die philosophie des geldes
in so einem zeitlosen raum in einer
gesellschaft wo man nicht mehr weiß
darüber dressieren eine moderne
entwickelte geldwirtschaft handelt zum
konkreten passt auch durch mitwirkung
hat mehr die intellektuelle
öffentlichkeit als die universität war
das liegt zum teil eben auch
antisemitismus derzeit man hat ihn
einfach nicht in den club reingelassen
erst spät hat er meine profi von leuten
in straßburg bekommen und war die ganze
zeit privatdozent in berlin war relativ
finanziell unabhängig muss das nun auch
bücher schnell veröffentlichen
in finanziellen problematischen
situationen war insofern der
öffentlichkeit immer ein sehr präsenter
intellektueller denn vorlesung war zum
teil richtige große ereignisse wie die
leute aus der tür aus stangen das wurde
dann in der tagespresse in bewegung er
hat viel gefehlt auch viele frauen da es
als unser modell
man kann es der film kaum vorstellen was
für eine intellektuelle präsenz nur
damals hatte die er später eben nach dem
zweiten weltkrieg nicht mehr erreicht
hat dazu dass wir von seinen
zeitgenossen kaum noch etwas erhalten
bei allem ein intellektueller flaneur
der umherschweifen durch texte aber auch
durch die straßen berlin
alles ist ihm wichtig und die botschaft
lautet alle tanzen philosophieren
anregenden ruine kaffeetasse aber eben
auch geld da steckt natürlich auch die
gefahr dass die kühlung komplett
abzudriften
aber genau das möchte im sinne nicht er
sieht sich als einen ernsthaften
sie besuchen auch ohne in ihrem ortsteil
ganz gut aufstellt und ernsthaftigkeit
vorgeworfen worden
diese philosophie vor allem in der
zweiten schaffensphase vertragen oder
gewählt von der idee des lebendigen das
kann man auch zusammenfassend sagen und
innerhalb dieser philosophie der
vierbändigen wird er gleicht geradezu
gefeiert gehuldigt überhöht es wird auch
die arten über den geist gesprochen wird
ist wie bei einem guten wein man
versucht irgendwelche absolute zu finden
was denn jetzt eigentlich der geist ist
aber unklar
was man aber sagen kann ist dass eben
simmel dem geist unter einer veränderten
gesellschaftlichen bedingungen hier ganz
neue kraft verleihen wollte also dass
der bund wird es da war den geist
lebendig zu halten heidelberg über
irgendeine portal später auch lebendige
geist dann bin ich vielen dank